new details this afternoon on a
kidnapping standoff and according to
Metro Police Murder in the southwest
Valley detectives say the suspect in
this case took his own life after the
domestic violence eight news now
reporter Lauren O'Grady live this
afternoon from the scene of the
kidnapping with the latest details
Lauren good afternoon
good afternoon John Metro Police say
this is where it all
all adnapped now Metro Police have not
yet identified her name released her
name but family members tell me the
victim is 38 year old Risa abreira she
is also the owner of the salon
detectives say she was kidnapped around
7 30 last night by her ex-boyfriend he
allegedly brought her to his home near
Fort Apache and sunset two other women
were also inside along with their
three-year-old child soon a standoff
with police began Metro Lieutenant Jason
Johan Jason Johansen says well one of
the women inside was able to leave with
a child abrera and her kidnapper were
not
into the residence they located the mail
in an upstairs room with a gunshot wound
to his head and they located the female
unresponsive
I spoke with the bearer's brother Rico
he says she was a beautiful person she
had Big Dreams and a bright future ahead
of her sadly it was cut short due to the
domestic violence now Metro Police have
not yet released the name of the man
however the coroner will hope will
officially release both their identities
hopefully later today live at Eastern
and Serene Lauren negretti 8 news now
all right Lauren thank you very much
police urge anyone who's at a domestic
violence situation to seek help we have
a list a lot of resources at
8newsnow.com